we'll be interviewed this evening by
Roenick desai who many of you know is a
second-year student and member of the
view from the top committee before
coming to the GSB Roenick worked for JP
Morgan and GE on the East Coast and then
worked in India for Genpact a subsidiary
of GE where he was vice president for
corporate development
let's welcome row neck to the GSB stage
as well well first of all good evening
everybody it's a it's a privilege to be
here and thank you all for for coming
and joining I have a cute I grew up in a
family where all we knew about business
school was Stanford my little brother
here one of my favorite people in the
world is has always been the biggest fan
and spokesperson for the school so it
was a no-brainer on one hand to come and
speak to the school but more importantly
just to have the opportunity to kind of
share some of my thoughts and I also I
did not realize I was going to be seeing
one of my other favorite people in life
Henry grows right behind my brother who
was he actually recruited me from
Princeton for my very first job was my
first boss so I think through the
evening you could ask him some Q&A about
what I was like I don't know if you want
to hear that answer but I tremendous
amount the whole reason I think I'm
probably here it started from the very
early days but before we get into some
Q&A I just thought I would give you a
just a quick snapshot of Who I am and I
think as you heard thank you for that
wonderful introduction and I won't go
that much into Avon it's um it is an
interesting company 140 something
countries you know well over ten billion
dollars today with six million Avon
representatives so I think we have more
Avon representatives than the army the
Air Force and the Navy combined in
Brazil and over a million won in China
so the numbers are huge but let me just
tell you one thing about myself which I
think will start this and that is that
um I I think I'm in this job 10 years
as of last Wednesday 10 years as a CEO
which my father he sent me an article he
usually doesn't do this that had on the
cover of Businessweek that the average
tenure was at that time 3.2 years and he
said to me with this big question mark
like are you coming home after this what
are you doing after this and I would say
to you first and foremost that you know
I have a love affair with my work in my
company I have not loved this job every
single day which we can talk about the
CEOs job after 40 public quarters
particularly in the last couple years is
not exactly what I would say is fun but
I have had a huge passion for it and I
guess I would just express this by
telling you that in 1997 I was on a
short list of I guess potential CEOs for
the company and there was a lot of
visibility on it for those of you who
are women in the audience because I
think at that time there was only one
woman maybe two Carly Fiorina and Marian
Sandler were the only two public company
CEOs at the time and so I was in line to
become the CEO of the company company
hit a sort of tough spot and the board
decided even though they had kind of
given me the nod that I would get the
job that they were going to go with one
of our directors a gentleman who had
been a CEO and was 52 years old so they
told me that I was not going to get the
job and that I could be the number two
and the papers and the New York Times
kind of really were all over that
because there was this whole
overwhelming women passed over there is
a glass ceiling reaction to it at which
point I got actually two other pretty
big CEO job offers so I was at this
inflection point because there I was the
boss that I was going to work for was 52
so it wasn't like he was 62 or they
could tell me just do this for a couple
years and then you'll get the job they
basically were saying he's here you you
are you're here to support him
and I was being offered the money the
title the corner office that came with
some pretty interesting benefits and a
mentor of mine said follow your compass
not your clock I just say that again she
said follow your compass not your clock
make this decision not from your head
but from your heart and that was the
biggest inflection point of my career I
made the decision that I love the
company
I loved its mission its purpose we were
in a tough time I love the people and I
decided that I love that more than I
loved the idea of being a CEO or
anything else that came with that that I
would rather be with the company and
work I loved then just do it for the
sake of the title end quote the path
that you were supposed to be achieving
and in that decision I think that
changed my life I changed my life
career-wise I will tell you you know it
didn't work out for him so I got the job
in 21 months in the rest is history but
I just I'm starting I'm starting to tell
you because I I don't know who else
would be here on view for the top
because I would make that decision again
even if I was still number two today
even if he were still a CEO and I were
the number two person I'm so passionate
about the work that I do and the
contribution that I think that the work
is making and I have a piece in that
that I would make that decision all over
again even if it hadn't turned out this
way and somebody else would be sitting
up here on view for the top and that
that's the most important thing that
before we even get into this that I I
want to share with you that if you don't
love the work and you all are about to
go out and do some pretty extraordinary
things I have had plenty of business
school friends as you can imagine after
I graduated from Princeton whether it
was from here or you know places on the
East Coast and and if the work and the
company was job or even a
year but not a passion they're still not
doing it and I am are you with me
they're they're not doing that anymore
other things children I have them other
things take precedence when it's not
deep passion for the work so I just that
that's the first thing I wanted to tell
you is that
luckily life turned out for me and I get
to be here and do this but it wouldn't
have mattered if it didn't because I've
actually found a company that it that I
love and that's the most important thing
I wanted to share with you before we
even started okay great well once again
thank you so much for joining us it's a
privilege to have you here just picking
them up on that theme of passion a
little bit I've read that you know your
parents believed in well-rounded
top-notch education they provided access
to piano lessons Mandarin lessons you
went to Princeton for your undergrad
education and when you first started a
career by taking up retail jobs from
what I've read at least there were a
little bit of gas and said hey yeah this
doesn't sound like a great career move
it sort of reminds me about my parents
is reacts when I told them I wasn't
going to be a doctor so starting
starting back then how did you manage to
stay true to your passion in your dreams
well I was interesting because I mean
mom and dad came from China came here to
give us education and hopefully you know
Ivy League education z' and then going
into not different than your parents
doctor lawyer or just something they
thought more intellectual than retail so
when I decided after Henry here it
recruited me to go and work in the
retail business I think their first
reaction was that that really wasn't
what we had in mind but then the family
values set in which were no matter what
it is you do then then you better go and
be your best you better go and you
better work hard and I remember oh gosh
it was just by Thanksgiving of that
first year in that training program and
I was changing hangers in a stockroom
and all I was doing was taking the
vendor hangers take it why are you f it
was written was worth that I'm being
very nice about this I was taking the
vendor hangers and putting the store
hangers on this thinking to myself I got
Princeton education to do this and I
remember one day saying and to my mom I
don't know I mean it yeah it's so it
could be really interesting but I really
feel like I'm doing some menial work
here and I don't know maybe maybe I
should quit and she said to me it took
left in a heartbeat she said to me quit
we don't quit in this family are you
kidding quit you start at the bottom and
you work your way up your what is it
that you are learning from that you are
not quitting I don't care who else is in
that training program that's quitting
will quit on anything in this family and
that that perseverance even though when
they quickly got over it now they think
it was great they tell the story they
have all the scrapbooks about it but
that wasn't like that
but that thought really was resident in
and I think you know our family's
culture so it was just whatever you
decide to do stick with it it's not
going to be easy
no no path to success comes without
stones in it so you know you have to
take some tough days you're gonna you're
not going to like it a lot of the time
but that's just part of it stick with it
don't quit sure so it sounds like your
parents did a great job of sort of
combining yeah you often get immigrant
values when you immigrate to the US with
sort of the American culture blending
into that you talk a little bit more
about that about how what kind of values
you grew up with and how do those
translate into the values you want to
leave for your children sure um you know
I I feel really proud that I haven't had
to change who I am to be successful in
this role dan Rather was doing the
series of interviews when I first became
the CEO of a couple of women executives
and he was actually went and interviewed
families parents and so he went they
went up and interviewed my parents my
mom cleaned the house they were trying
to serve him Chinese food
and they you know they do this huge
thing for like hours and hours and you
know how well those of you know media I
mean they shrunk it down to about a
20-second soundbite after interviewing
for hours and hours and hours with all
of this and they take it down to one
soundbite on television where he's
asking my father so did you always know
that your daughter was going to be a
successful CEO and he says on public
television as a matter of fact quite the
opposite um you know we raised her we
raised our kids as pretty traditional
Chinese Family Values and my perception
of CEOs really hardcore cutthroat I
really can't imagine that she's going to
actually be that successful I'm thinking
this is probably Stevie so um but the
truth is in that thought was the fear I
think that my family value system had
that the concept of being kind about
caring about people about being
respectful would go get washed out of
the window in a very you know very in
his mind typical behaviors required in
the corner office and have I had to
change some things yes I mean I I think
I am much more assertive I mean you know
kind of growing up in an Asian
background sort of avoid conflict around
the dinner table is the thought you
don't argue about things and I have had
to become more assertive and have
understand the role of constructive
conflict I don't think I'm aggressive I
don't think I've had to change my
personality or Who I am or my value
system and you know so I think the the
best thing my parents would say about me
I hope but and they say it now and makes
me happy as this will they say well
she's really still the same person even
though you know she's on some list
someplace and that's what I hope my
children realize is that those values
are more important than anything else
that's great how does that translate
mean you've got five point five and a
half million sales representatives
around the world how does that play into
how you motivate them how you get them
inspired and I lead the organization
well it's interesting because they are
they are independent representatives so
I underline that word I mean different
than I guess other CEOs there they're
not my employees they don't have to work
for me every day so I can't tell them
what to do you know you learn and the
skill is interesting one and I guess it
applies anywhere whether I guess it's
politics or anything else I mean
influence is a very different thing
motivation inspiration and influence are
very different things than leadership
requirements and mandates and so you
know this skill of communicating is the
skill of influencing and inspiring and
mission and values and purpose have been
the way that we've effectively kept that
sales force going this year you and I
had a little conversation on the way
over but you know no different than any
other company 2009 you go into the buzz
saw of the global economic crisis a year
ago and everybody's like okay we got a
cut we've got to freeze salaries we're
not going to hire we're going to do let
you know whatever all the the things
that just come flying at you as a CEO
and we decided that we needed to keep
our people motivated but more
importantly you know go back to the
original purpose of the company in order
to find the answer for the way we were
going to get through this year and that
was that you know the company was 123
years old and the the founder actually
was a man who believed that women should
be economically empowered I mean I
actually love the story he was a
encyclopedia salesman and all of the
direct sale sellers were men at the time
and somebody gave him about a vial of
perfume one Christmas and he realized
everybody who was home were the women
and they were basically saying to him we
don't want the books can we just buy the
perfume that you were supposed
to give as a gift with it so he realized
there was something there but the most
important thing he did because it was
1886 was decide that the seller wouldn't
be men that he was going to actually
employ a woman which was heretical at
the time because women weren't even
allowed to vote nevermind make money
outside of the home and so it was not
popular in the beginning but he actually
went out and and created the first woman
Salesforce and became the economic
solution for women here in the United
States and that has transferred to 140
countries now and you can imagine its
power in India and in all of the
emerging economies but we decided in
2009 with unemployment
you know predicted and now we see over
10 percent here and rampant everywhere
else that you know we're going to be a
solution that the company's not just
going to be about earnings per share and
everything else that we're actually
going to have the business purpose to be
a solution to governments and
unemployment right now and we were going
to go out and be very aggressive about
telling women that they could earn if
they got laid off of their husbands got
laid off where they wanted extra income
and it's been extremely motivating and
it's almost no language necessary when
you have mission and purpose we did a
very bold thing you know a lot of people
were cutting back on advertising we
decided we're going to advertise I
remember the day I said we're gonna
advertise on the Super Bowl this year
and people were like yeah the Super Bowl
a it's expensive B you know it you know
it's it's Budweiser I mean what those
are the kind of products so Andrea are
we gonna advertise skincare or lipstick
and I said neither we're going to create
an ad a testimonial ad of people who've
joined us since they got laid off and
they're going to tell their story
everybody's looked at us and we said we
went out and we created a very
compelling ad where the message was
authentic and genuine people really said
I can't get laid off I'm running my own
business they're mine on ours it's my
own business my job and we ran it and
the phone was off the hook
before halftime as you can imagine for
all the women watching at the same time
from the pregame on and this began what
has become probably more people who've
joined then certainly in the United
States since the 70s it's been it's been
an amazing thing but it was this
proactive message that entrepreneurship
is in and it's important and it's part
of the economy's solution based on
everything you said whereas we walked
over and now it seems like you've got
you know great your finger on the pulse
of your organization often MCS say it's
lonely at the top and I was wondering
how you sort of combat that and how do
you get beyond sort of the walls of the
executive suite yeah I think it's
important it's actually interesting and
difficult not difficult but you know I
it's a vertical company which I love I
mean so we do everything from product
development all the way out to the end
consumer so we are completely vertical
which is wonderful but it's also insular
you know and you can get isolated
because you're not trying to get the
endcap at Walmart or you know trying to
get the order versus L'Oreal or anybody
else in the department store so we own
the chain but worried that our people
just get too myopic so for me it's a
couple things I guess one is very
selectively making sure that I had an
outside-in perspective so I'm on two
boards as you heard I'm on General
Electric's board and Apple completely
different and I can talk about that in a
minute but they've really helped me stay
current and forced me to kind of
reassess my own skills I'm out in the
field a lot I mean I I think I mean I
was an Avon representative when I joined
in every other year I signed up and
become an Avon representative and hope
nobody recognizes me and go out and try
and sell which is extraordinarily you
it's very very humbling but and I try
and and really get people to tell me the
good bad and the ugly particularly the
latter it's it is isolated I don't know
that the word is lonely but you know
people aren't going to come and say you
know what Andrea
in this meeting this is what you did
wrong you shut people down you didn't
listen I mean you know that kind of
feedback sounds good on paper but it
just doesn't happen
so trying to have the ability to have
your your top team feel the informal and
formal way to give you feedback to tell
you what you're not doing wrong so that
you can reinvent yourself it's pretty
important pretty important picking up on
your two boards I'm sure we don't love
to know kind of how you view your
leadership tile is being different from
Steve Jobs as you're Jeff and notes in
particular what you think Jeff and Jack
before I didn't wear my jeans in my
black but mark told me I needed to wear
soon very different fascinating
experiences so I was um you know I mean
in this day and age tough too tough to
find the time because I think boards
take on I mean I think this is this is a
world and speaking for a second just
being a director the responsibility of
being a public company director
obviously is huge these days and the
commitment really is time consuming but
I was on GES board since actually before
I became the CEO at Avon so I've been on
that board 11 years now and was pretty
much exclusively on one board until I
joined Apple in nineteen 2008 so it was
ten years before I joined a second board
and I I did that I mean GE has been
extraordinary its I didn't go to
business school my secret I wish I had
come here but since I didn't I didn't go
to business school and in a way it has
been my business school from from
everything of a process point of view on
one hand you would say aircraft engines
power systems medical systems a lipstick
and skin care completely different
businesses on the other hand the
processes globalization quality programs
how they do things across the
as you know are hugely beneficial to any
business leader so that that has been
enormous the talent process at GE is
second to none I mean the from the
training to the succession planning and
the depth
I have brought so much back I am that
much better a leader and we were when I
when I started the company we were what
3 billion dollars and I think four and
change when I became the CEO and it'll
be eleven billion dollars so you know to
run a ten billion dollar plus company
versus five I mean you would think I'm
it's completely different and the the
process that's necessary because we were
a very entrepreneurial company but you
know you need the systems and the
processes you want to keep a combination
of instinct and in facts but we needed
them and I learned a tremendous amount
of that we would not be the company that
I think that we are today if I hadn't
learned what I did from from being at GE
the succession planning process at GE
you know the decision how Jack made the
decision you know that just how he
thought about that was beyond
fascinating I was on that committee and
that that was enormous ly fascinating so
then fast forward to you know I had had
known Steve always a huge admirer of the
company and one day I got a phone call
and he just said you know he was in New
York and he came up showed me the new
Nano and we had a great conversation and
you know he asked me to be on the board
and the rest has been history it's been
it's so different on the other hand I
mean but I don't leave that meeting and
I have it tomorrow without thinking god
I need to be a better CEO when I walk
out the you think I think I like to
think that I am you know in touch with
the consumer have passion for product
the the user experience but it just
pales I mean they're there the whole
company not just Steve but the company
is as I'm sure you all know just
maniacal and fanatical about excellence
whether it's we're going to go into the
retail business whether we're going to
go into the
gaming business whether we're going to
go into the phone business it's it's
just a laser focus I I think what they
say no to is as important as what they
say yes to and that discipline is
something that I have definitely learned
from when I come back and try and run
the company but just this is consumer
marketer I always leave they're going oh
gosh I've got to be better when I go
back tomorrow
better better look at that bottle one
more time the curvature is not too
perfect
given that you're here for the board
meeting uh I'm sure we'd love to know
when the Apple tablets coming up Thanks
I'm sure you one more question before we
open it up to to the audience based on
you know a lot of what you've spoken
about has been reinventing yourself as
either the environments changed or avons
business has changed I just want
wondering if you could speak a little
bit about how you reinvent yourself as a
CEO and how do you take a step back
reexamine and hear something different
what I think you know the company we
like to say is 123 years young and the
only way to do that I mean you can't
reinvent a company without reinventing
yourself first so reinvention of a brand
or reinvention of a company is only as
good as the reinvention of the leader
and the leaders and it is interesting
and being in the job ten years and yeah
it's a huge privilege on one hand I
actually don't know how people are kind
of coming into this job in this
environment and having to kind of put
all truths over here and start fresh
having had a decade of having to go
through cycles and reinvent myself and
learn from my own mistakes I think has
clearly been an enabler to getting
through this environment but I'll tell
you one story in so the first five years
I was a growth CEO I mean we were
booming into emerging markets we had
double-digit top-line growth 25 percent
earnings growth for five years running
and I mean I never did a layoff I had no
idea what the word turnaround man and we
hit the wall you know as all businesses
do and if you're in any job long enough
I can promise you there is a cycle
whether it's silk their businesses are
cyclical whether it's farm at you you
name it there's always cycles so I've
done probably longer than not without
hitting the wall but we hit the wall in
2005 and we at that time gave earnings
guidance and we missed guidance twice in
I don't know four months and I don't
know if some of you know Ram Sharan who
is sort of a coach and friend to CEOs
he's been a friend of mine for a long
time but he came up into my office on a
Friday night and he said to me you want
some tough love and I said sure
and he said to me the board loves you
people in this company love you but in
about 120 days they're going to have to
fire you I just looked at them and he
said you do understand that right I mean
unfortunately when you're in this job
you got shareholders I mean if you can't
turn this around if you can't look at
this thing with new eyes it's going to
kill them but they're not going to have
a choice I said well well that was
pretty tough flow and and he was right
earlier that week one of the people that
work for me said you know what when I
was at I've got these people that want
to come in because when I was at AT&T
they had 15 layers of management and
they had this exercise which then became
really very strategic where they took
out 30% of management and and seven or
eight layers because people were too far
from the consumer and too far from you
know the business and they had built as
all businesses do of bureaucracy and so
I think we should look at this and I
said you know I tell me a little bit
more and she said well probably one out
of three middle to senior managers gonna
have to go
and I said look we have all these
initiatives but we're really a people
based businesses we're not capital
intensive we're people intensive we have
so many countries the operating model is
not mature enough yet or matrix enough
for us to take out the people I
understand the concept I just don't I
don't think we can do that I mean I
think that would take it I don't think
we have the capacity I don't think we
can do that that was Monday Friday night
he says to me if you think about this
this is what's going to happen Andrea so
you're going to get fired if you don't
turn this around but then because you've
got it you know
the history and the track record
Heydrich is going to call you and
they're going to put you into another
company and then you're going to be the
turnaround CEO who gets to look at
everything fresh you won't know any of
the people you won't have any you know
allegiance to the strategies and you're
going to go in and be able to just cut
do and change because you'll be
objective
so you have to make a choice go home
it's Friday night if you can't come in
on Monday morning and reinvent yourself
and pretend you just got hired here and
you're going to look at everything your
team your strategies your organizational
structure and if you can't do the things
that a turnaround person would do if
they came in here Monday morning I
wouldn't put big bets on it if you can
you will be far better than anybody else
good because you know where every you
know Rock is you know every single thing
about it and you've got the latent
goodwill and equity that you've built up
so you make the choice so that's what I
did I went home and I thought about it
and I came in Monday morning and we took
out eight layers we had we went forward
and reshaped I had um very hard look at
some people who were terrific friends
but and got us from you know three
billion to six billion but weren't going
to get us to 11 and I made all the hard
calls with the right values in in the
rest he's been the last few years but
you know I had to become a definer of my
own second chapter and started afresh so
it was it's been like a new job Wow
thank you for your candor what that
would love to open up to the audience
for questions and their mics roaming on
the sides
thanks for joining us Andrea I believe
you developed your passion for playing
the piano at a very early age could you
talk a little bit about how that
influenced you through your life I have
you and also a little bit about how your
passions and interests are outside of
work at this stage in your life well I
have very little time anymore to play
and I actually had a piano teacher a few
years ago who dropped me because he said
to me you keep going on trips and you
keep carefully on yourself
I'm not going to take you until you get
a little bit of calmness in your life
interestingly and Mark could probably
say the same thing we used to have to we
had not only a metronome on the piano
but a timer and this was our first
example of discipline when it was an
hour I mean if if it was like 50 minutes
and we wanted to go play tennis or what
there was no getting up I mean it was
one hour of that discipline and besides
sort of passion for classical music the
one of the first things that I recall in
terms of self discipline in my life was
remembering that you know what it's 59
minutes and it's not - it's 60 that you
keep working at something so you know
that that that is one of the things I
think that it's given it's
extraordinarily I think important to
have an appreciation I was an English
major but just for the Arts you know you
sit there in business and someone some
people say to me you an English major
and you know you're writing in shorthand
email at this point that's that's the
extent of your your writing and it's
really not because I think just the
critical thinking and the the ability to
communicate to communicate and to have
people understand where we're going and
what the vision is I think much of that
I can kind of go back go back to my
education and remember and it's had
application
you mentioned how you're able to
motivate and inspire your own employees
you also mentioned how the lessons that
you've learned from the other boards
that you serve on I'm wondering how
you've been able to adjust your
leadership style to mauvais inspire
these more technology-based companies
and these almost bigger than life
personalities these male leaders at
those companies I think that you know
the experiences that I've had at the
company as well as my own vantage point
has been a different and interesting
addition to the boards that I've been on
the global experience you know our our
business in China for example you know
where we have write direct touch
consumer insights in an understanding of
in our case you know a million won
sellers who have millions of consumers
in all the small towns and villages one
of the things that just so I'll use that
example and it's been a lot of time
talking about that with Jeff Immelt or
Steve but we we decided it Avon not to
focus on the eastern seaboard cities the
large cities we decided to penetrate the
small towns and villages and have a
supply chain and infrastructure strategy
where the women were because we knew
that the government would like the fact
that we were offering opportunities for
people not to have to bust themselves to
work in two large cities that we could
create work for them right in the towns
and villages where they were and those
insights and the behavior and the
opportunity to understand consumers and
what they will do and what they will pay
in those countries those are some of the
insights I think I've been able to bring
very different personalities so they
mean two very different men and two very
different corporate cultures and ours is
completely different too and it is
interesting to to weigh and balance that
so again even though
Avon is different from either of those
two those two couldn't be more different
either but both with enormous strengths
you spoke earlier about it being tough
to get critical feedback at times I was
just curious about over the years ways
you've figured out to solicit difficult
feedback from your own staff on how you
guys can prove and yeah from a formal
point of view we do and I do a mandatory
anonymous 360 with all of my reports
every year I make them fill out a pretty
tough tough thing about you know there'd
either toughest moment with me or where
they really didn't think I led well what
they would think I need to do and again
not attributed and and we we have a
discussion about that with all of them
there and somebody from the outside who
co-leads that every every single year
and that's extremely helpful
I also encourage them and I guess I've
been in the role long enough so there's
there's a amount of trust there for them
you know I'm a big believer in immediate
feedback you know I fundamentally
believe that if the first time you're
hearing something negative about
yourself is in your performance
appraisal then your boss is doing the
wrong job I mean I'm a real believer
right in that meeting if I think that
you're you didn't handle something well
I don't do it in front of everybody I
don't believe that's the right thing to
do but I will call you in afterwards and
just say look by the way in that meeting
this this was handled right I expect you
to do X Y & Z and we won't even be we're
anywhere near or we have to wait until a
mid-year or a full-year review but they
know that I do that and I expect them to
do the same thing for me so I they know
from this formal feedback what I think
my derailleurs are the things that I
tend to do wrong are and I ask them to
help me with that so if they notice it
or they see it under stress coming out
more that they'll just catch me on it
just say you know by the way you know
today you seem like you really are kind
of doing X Y or Z and it catches me on
that so thoughtful
hi Andrea thank you for joining us
you're welcome
out of curiosity do you feel there still
is a glass ceiling and if so what do you
think the next generation of leaders can
do to change that it's a great question
um you know I think the numbers by
themselves would say there's still
somewhat of a glass ceiling I mean 15
out of 500
you know I guess women in on the fortune
500 would say there's there's room to go
but having said that I am a real
believer that the playing field is
changing and what do I mean by that when
I go back even five years never mind
when I became the CEO most women in not
a CEO job but in the level underneath
were in what I would call the the staff
jobs corporate communications HR they
were not in CFO roles or the the leading
operating unit roles if you look today
well the number may be small in the nut
the with the level below of women ready
to take on the number one job or in the
importance C jobs the c-suite job it's
so dimensional that I think the next
five years is going to be huge in terms
of women in top leadership roles in in
in business so I think we are in a in a
very very different moment also in terms
of me I mean you know I I keep saying
you know there's these lists which I
believe that when the lists go away of
top whatever women will really have made
it but right now while there are still
lists you know I'm hoping that I keep
going down what do I mean by that
because I mean my company's big but
there are people in much bigger jobs now
in the tongue of Fortune 50 companies
and and so women are not only breaking
through but they're breaking through
with some pretty big roles which I think
hopefully is true in politics is in
business so I think it's the jobs and
the companies they're leading as well as
the number of them who are ready to take
on pretty large roles very very
different than even five years ago so I
think the glass is very half-full more
than half-full on that front so it's a
it's a different time if women want it
you know I mean I think that it's high
my questions are how have you stay
innovative in the consumer product space
over the last 10 years and especially
kind of where the challenges and best
practices and leading and guiding that
innovation in the space that's a great
question how do how do I stay innovative
or out of one stay innovative I mean I
think you know you guys are probably
learning this more than anyone that is
that innovation is so key I think this
is more important than ever I think that
the worst thing that can happen in this
economy is for people to cut back R&D
spend I mean if you kind of look at you
know I I have studied that the actual
market share gains and losses in normal
or healthy economies it's pretty hard
when you're large to kind of get half a
point of market share or a point takes a
long time and so in in normal times it's
it's hard but in this the worst
economies they say that that's when
disruptive shared gains or losses when
industries go out and companies can go
from bottom quartile to completely top
if they are on top of innovation so
really I'm a huge believer this is
actually a seminal moment for companies
to invest and I think it's a combination
of things look one thing and I believe
this is that there there's a deal of
instinct that that's important in
innovation I think you can't always find
it going back or in facts or analytics
or I mean if you really you have to have
I think some arc the art of it and the
instinct of it as well as the science
and facts but you know the consumer
herself or himself will will tell you a
good amount of the answer I mean you
know you can be searching out there but
if you really listen and and have the
constant tentacles into I find some of
the biggest answers in the customer
complaint area if you go into your call
center your customer complaint area
about your products and/or services you
know right in there from what they don't
like is the answer to what you can do
so it is just go in there sit there
listen to the phone pick it up I've done
that for a couple hours you know every
once in a while and you can get a
tremendous amount there there's great
partners I think innovation is it's got
to be outside in not just inside out Rd
lots of big companies P&G is a great
example who used to be more insular in
terms of their innovation are doing
partnering partnering with universities
partnering with individuals just trying
to get more outside in innovation and so
for a company like ours where we maybe
had our R&D did 85% of our innovation
I'm hoping it'll be 50% in the next
couple years really trying to seek
because we have an entrepreneurship
culture one of the things that we did in
this brand that we have called mark
which really was not named after mark
but it got a lot of brownie points at
home but the point of the brand was you
know women making their own mark on the
world but one of the things that we did
one of the things that we did was open
innovation from consumers so if you we
call it a participative brand so if you
are in Australia and it means everybody
there's so many people who have a great
idea for a makeup product if you've got
a great idea in Australia you can send
that in to us and it can be part of the
brand and so and it can even on the
inside of our packaging on the card and
it would say you know Suzy Smith
Australia Avon representative and so
what we're trying to do is is have
people virally who have great ideas
because we're not too preneur companies
say you can give us a product and maybe
if you keep selling enough of this we
can help seed fund you to start your own
makeup business why not and we've gotten
some pretty enormous ly interesting
ideas right from our own consumer and or
our seller base I'm a firm believer in a
professional mom I wonder if you could
give us some information on how you
divide your time and make sure you get
these disciplines across your children
and and do the bang-up job at home as
you do okay well my answer for this
which his evolved is the following I
mean I don't know I'm sure there are
some people who can get it all done in
one day I am NOT one of them but I
really believe two things one is there
it's all about prioritization there are
days that my children absolutely win in
the company does not there are also days
where the company has to win and they
don't and I think I have made the right
choice with the right priority so the
day's Avon lose I don't feel guilty if
I'm not at a meeting years ago I would
not go to an Avon meeting and I would
feel guilty about it the whole time I
don't do that anymore
my probably best example is this time it
was this couple of administration's ago
so it was George W Bush and they were
inviting eight CEOs to the White House
that was the only woman
invited on a specific topic and it was
also the first day that my daughter was
going away to a camp that mothers were
going to take their kids to the bus and
you know it was one of those things
where it was like a split second I mean
I really thought George W is never going
to remember if I am at that luncheon but
my daughter is going to remember one way
or another for the probably the rest of
her life so I didn't go to the White
House I got a chance to go another time
but and you know that that decision was
an easy one
have I missed a game yes have I met the
most important one no have I missed a
meeting at work yes the most important
one No so for me it's just you know
making it making a decision like that
and and living with it you know I think
you also have to have a sense of humor I
remember this was in the Jack Welsh
succession moment and we had a Saturday
morning call and we were all pining on
who we felt Jack at a point of view
should be in the succession for GE and
it was the day of my son's third
birthday party and I was at a Jodi's gym
and I don't ask why but I could not
figure out how to use the mute button on
the cell phone so I was in an electrical
closet taking this call and so you'd be
if they'd be like okay so senator nunn
what do you think and he's he's up
hiding in the closet burst open and my
son's like it's the wrong scooby-doo
he's the wrong brown
I am like this I will buy you ten more
presents if you leave this electrical
closet and of course you wouldn't
so we he's the wrong one David had the
other one you have the wrong one so that
the whole GE Board those who are still
on the border like wrong color
scooby-doo injure yourself but you have
to have a sense of humor about it and
it's it's real and it's life in addition
to having a social mission is kind of
core to the corporate mission the Avon
is very involved in some philanthropic
efforts I was wondering if you could
speak a little bit more about those and
also as a public company if you receive
any resistance from some of the
stakeholders that might be concerned
that it's either unrelated or perhaps
detrimental to the bottom line well let
me just start by saying there's a I I
read a lot of business books as I'm sure
you have I mean so I pretty much read
them all but one of my favorites is good
to great by Jim Collins and the last
paragraph of Jim Collins book has always
struck me if you go back and read it it
basically says that it is impossible to
have a meaningful life without
meaningful work and that in order to
have meaningful work it really is about
the purpose and that if you can find
work where it actually matters not about
shareholder but it but the work actually
matters in life you can then have a
great life and I'm a huge personal
believer in that so we have a foundation
we've raised seven hundred twenty five
million dollars so that's the largest
kind of women's foundation mostly
towards women's health and violence and
oppression against women issues and it's
men and women alike in the company are
equally passionate about the fact that
you know we do good as well as do well
and it is really part of the corporate
culture it's not about check-writing I
mean uh people participate they they
walk they they are deeply deeply
involved in it and I
think it continues to make a difference
from a public company point of view we
do get at the shareholder meeting you
know the in the old adage that no good
deed goes unpunished you do you do have
we do have some activists who come in
not so much that it's you know it goes
against public company profits because
in fact I can argue that it's helped to
brand equity and has helped revenues and
associations with companies that do well
I think there's enough of companies like
us that can prove that it that it's an
enhancement to brand equity but you know
we'll we'll have our share of activists
who kind of want to pick on certain
things but in general I think there's a
pretty direct correlation to the fact
that when it's not just over here when
the when the work of a company whether
its sustainability
you know the Walmart I mean what lots of
company halves have really proven that
when you are doing the right thing for
community for society it is it is
Trump's and really adds to corporate
revenues and profitability so a big
believer in that so you're in a hundred
and forty companies so some democracies
some dictatorships how do you see your
company interacting with different forms
of government and what do you foresee
you got to do the United States as the
government becomes more activist well I
think that you know certainly in the
United States but in general as we like
to say in business I mean with
regulators and the government is taking
a larger and larger role they've moved
in next door and they're not moving out
everywhere and so I think the role of
government relations for a company you
know we're not highly regulated but even
for us the role of government relations
and your Washington contingent or your
industry groups that are representing
you are much more critically important
and I think it's in important have the
opportunity to to talk with some of the
staff and make sure that in Washington
that
companies are being heard I think the
first few months was so primarily
focused on the financial sector and then
auto that really being able to hear the
voice of consumer companies and other
industry companies and understanding tax
legislation implications healthcare
implications is is critical for consumer
companies I mean the number one issue in
my mind is unemployment and the stimulus
money getting back into the economy to
create the jobs because in a consumption
based economy where unemployment is over
10% that is tough for structural
recovery of consumer spending and so
that that's certainly I think for
developed markets remains a challenge
but it's a new world order for for
companies with government quote
intervention and/or regulation and
having the ability to work with
governments partner and be heard is
important much more so than it was when
I took over and ten years ago this is a
whole nother ballgame but you know I
think I think the vehicles the forums
are are expanding so I'm encouraged on
their front there's there's a lot of
time being spent now listening which I
feel good about Rebecca last questions
all yours
so as Business School students were
obviously pretty early still in our
careers and I was wondering if you could
talk about kind of how you shape the
trajectory of your career and what sort
of criteria you use to base and the
initial steps and positions that you had
when you were younger
well one I I've mentioned probably the
most important inflection point for me
to make a decision which was to really
choose what you love as opposed to what
necessarily you think you should be
doing and or tying it to income and or
or title I think the other thing that I
would say is I'm I had spent most of my
early career in retail and then higher
in retail and
from a non-emotional point of view on
the avon front but on sort of vids I
really took I think a risk when I left
high-end retail and went to Avon you
know people were like what why are you
doing that I mean you know dingdong the
Avon lady
now what I'd never even seen an Avon
representative are you you know that's a
really dated brand and I felt that it
would be a real challenge I thought it
was different alternative distribution
I think distribution is key a lot of
people talk about branding but I think
he who wins the distribution game look
at Amazon I mean that that's all I would
say just but you're in the consumer
space he or she who can nail and
reinvent the distribution game will win
branding is critical that's the cost of
entry now distribution is the final
Trump but it was an alternative
distribution channel and it was global
and and I would say to you just you can
take 2009 you can have an economic
recovery projected in 2010 and 11 GDPs
in the developing emerging world is
where the growth is in the world I mean
you can't run from the fact that
economically it is global companies who
truly have presence and I know whether
it's programs here that involve really
just getting out there and understanding
those economies being able to work in a
company and work in those environments
you know culturally as well as
understand the business levers for
growth the line share of the growth I
mean in our industry and so shave it in
our industry 88 percent of the growth
between 20 2008 and 2013 in the in the
category is going to come from the
developing emerging markets through 2013
so going to be humbling like that every
place and being able to operate there I
think is important but choosing a global
company one with an alternative
distribution system and one that really
needed a turnaround were a betta bet a
big bet and that that was important the
other thing in my career I would say
that I have always done is tried to do
something outside my job
in other words
example would be I was in charge of
domestic marketing you know you know for
the domestic division and they needed
somebody to kind of take on
globalization which was very unpopular
in our company at the time it was sort
of the not invented here syndrome was
alive and well and everyone wanted to do
their own marketing when I came to the
company the first day I came there were
we put on a table one fragrance it was
83 versions this country didn't like the
color this country didn't like the name
this country didn't like smell I mean it
was just you know it was a decentralized
as it could be and someone had to take
on the ugly job if you would of really
trying to centralize and that was a
really tough word and so I did it in
addition to my day job I took it on and
it was unpopular but I got visibility
obviously to the top because they wanted
to understand if we could go left or
right on this and that probably was
pretty pretty a big deal from a career
point of view - thank you so much thank
you everybody
you